foreign
[Music]
so I had the idea to do this this fake
movie trailer I wanted to do a um a
biopic trailer about someone who was
still alive and to just make everything
up like something you could clearly fact
check
um and uh and I thought I had the idea
to do it about Weird Al and we had a
mutual friend in Patton Oswalt and I had
Patton reach out just to get Al's
blessing because I thought maybe it was
an idea that he wanted to do himself
you know I'm like I don't want to steal
something that eventually it feels a bit
like a very weird Al kind of idea and uh
Patton was like can I share your email
with him and like
10 minutes later I had an email from
Weird Al who I'd never met and uh he was
like yeah I know I'm familiar with your
stuff I love this idea I'd love to
collaborate with you on it and like that
evening I was getting coffee with him
and like watching trailers the internet
was a beautiful thing in 2009 yeah it's
just all peace and love and joy yeah and
comedy celebrities just wanting to be in
videos for free
let's go back to those days yeah
wow yeah so he was that was one of my
questions so he was involved in the in
the in the trailer yeah we just we we
the two of us watched a bunch of biopic
trailers
um and sort of
you know if you think biopics in their
entirety are are a little bit formulaic
the trailer is even more so when we were
putting the trailer together for this
movie I I was like went back to sort of
analyzing biopic trailers and at um in a
two minute 30 second trailer between one
minute and 40 seconds and one minute and
55 seconds in every musical biopic
trailer when it says this summer or this
fall or the actor's name there's like a
big tone shift where it like goes into
the big ballad or something every single
one of them the same thing like all the
the emotional scenes yeah in the back uh
the back third
so but so that was 12 years ago yeah
you've always been doing a ton of great
stuff since then but what led you to
want to go back and revisit Al
um it was Al that um he you know he
really dug how the trailer came out and
he started showing it as at his concerts
so for for a decade during a costume
change in the middle of the show
um this trailer would play and after the
show he does meet and greets and people
would always come up to him and either
say
um oh you have to make that movie or
I've looked for that movie and I can't
find it
and uh then in uh
February of 2019 I got like an email
from Al out of the blue that was just
like I mean it explained that and it
said
um you know with Bohemian Rhapsody and
Rocket man's gonna be coming out soon
and all of these biopics that have been
announced I feel like the time might be
right to turn this into a movie which at
the time we were like oh it's it's a
sketch you know it's a little free
minute thing and um
yeah that's that's that's and I met him
for coffee the next morning and and
Pablo Escobar came out of that first
coffee serious Al had just binge watched
narcos
and he was like you know I'd love for
there to be a part of the movie where
just randomly I'm like John Wick
fighting uh Pablo Escobar and I was like
wow all right sure okay yeah yeah man
I'm in let's make it work yeah and then
he really held on to that idea too right
because like a few times we were just
like are you sure yeah yeah yeah and
also like can we afford this like the
jungles of Colombia is just like I'm not
making the movie unless I'm in the
jungles of Columbia it's like you're the
boss Al yeah I said I was like you know
it's going to be the that's going to be
the first because he was like it needs
to come out of the blue and I'm like
okay all right but you know someone has
to pay for this movie to get married and
I feel like that's the first thing
they're gonna say cut unless
we like packet full of payoffs and we
like have the emotional like resolution
to the movie you know it has to like it
has to show up and be random at first
but by the end of it
it's like well I guess
Colombia had to happen like this Pablo
Escobar scene had to happen and that's
why we did the Madonna thing I feel like
the medallions were like invented for
that scene and then planted earlier
amazing yeah yeah
well I mean I have to say like just as a
general like my reaction is
the short is so funny but it it's a
short it's a sketch and what's
remarkable about this film is you it's a
feature length version of that and it
totally works like you sustain it it's
engaging it's interesting thank you it's
funny throughout and it does have like
emotional colors to it right it's not
just an overextended sketch so it's
thank you thank you for saying that yeah
yeah that's that's sort of
I mean that was like the toughest needle
with red you know it was a kind of
um yeah it all sort of like lands on the
tone of it and it was yeah you know
there's a lot of
there's jokes that ended up on The
Cutting Room floor like sillier gags
that feel a little more like airplane or
or Naked Gun and
I heard a couple odds I know we hated we
hated cutting them too
um I always say that if you know after
this comes out on Roku if there's a
release the Yankovic cut
um hashtag campaign that starts maybe
someday you will see there's like an
additional 20 minutes of like jokes that
are gone out of this yeah that are just
like really moments that like break the
tension or you know
just sort of step on the tone we're
going for and you know once once you
sort of break that in a scene you don't
get it back and suddenly you find
yourself
not caring about the character as much
and then it just and then it starts to
feel like an over long sketch yeah yeah
yeah really to Eric's credit from the
first video through the movie there were
a few of those but like he's always had
such a handle on what he wanted the
comedy and the tone to be and the
performances like we work together at
funnier dive for probably three years or
thereabouts and he always had great
instincts when it came to Casting also
and and how to blend comedians with
dramatic actors in a way to kind of
really get that balance and that emotion
that you typically don't see in just
like a straight parody uh thank you Mike
the the uh uh we want to talk about a
couple of the wild swings we took for
Weird Al first trailer yeah so when I
was looking at that email today just in
anticipation of this the the very first
person that we asked and was
subsequently passed on uh to play Al and
the trailer was Justin Timberlake
which I had a great feeling about of
course I always had a great feeling
about everyone
and then there were a few more though I
think you remember Tom Cruise
yeah I did have the heart to tell you
over email I don't know if I ever made
the office no I know I know yeah the the
email chain I think actually well I
don't know the exact order but I know
from the email Sam Rockwell oh wow I
forgot about that uh Edward Norton I
know that Edward Noreen I knew his uh
wife so I went through Sean Robertson to
no avail yeah by the way if like you you
enjoyed any of the early funnier Die
videos it's all like this guy pulled in
Talent like I I it's like unreal yeah
please please give it up
um yeah because I started working there
like maybe a month before you yeah
summer of 2000 yeah and it was like when
I got there you know it was like you
want a celebrity in your video pick up
the phone and call an agency and be like
hi can I speak to uh Sam Rockwell's
agent please I'm from the website that
Will Ferrell uh so if there's a video
called the landlord uh and then Mike
came in and like everything changed
there and that's when you know that's
when we started getting all the big uh
big celebrity videos and everything
So speaking of talent when did uh Daniel
Radcliffe get involved yeah so and when
did you think of him as somebody for
this part yeah I mean we just we kind of
put together a short list of actors that
we um that we wanted to go out to uh
Radcliffe was like very early on that
list and quickly Rose to the top of it
um just being someone who's such a great
dramatic actor
obviously he carried like an entire
movie franchise for a decade as a child
so like he's incredible
um and uh he but you know his post Harry
Potter work he's such a great comedic
actor too and makes some pretty Bonkers
choices so all of that stuff together
we're like I feel like
this guy's gonna get it
um and he's also going to be someone
who's like
not gonna try to push the comedy and
that like he's gonna play it really
grounded in this crazy universe that
we've created and uh and really lean
into this this tone
um so yeah we sent it to him and I I
want to say like a week later we were
having a a zoom with him this is right
before Zoom this is right before the
pandemic we were having a Google Hangout
I don't know what we did back then
um but uh but he was like immediately in
yeah he was like folks should know this
is rarely how it goes well you rarely
have Weird Al Yankovic attached to the
movie too but it wasn't set up it was
just totally a spec script yeah so to
his credit his team got it really
quickly he read it quickly you guys had
that zoom and basically he signed on
from there yeah by the end of that by
the end of that that video chat he was
like so uh what tell me what kind of
accordion again I want to start
practicing accordion now
um and and we got off at like I called
each other and we're like did so I mean
I think he that's great right he's in he
wants to do it like I'm like yeah these
he wants to buy an accordion sure yeah
it's I mean it's interesting because he
is grounded as you said but he like for
this to work you need an actor who's
going to fully commit and go everywhere
the movie goes which he does yeah and in
the short Aaron Paul is the same kind of
actor right you just will go anywhere
yeah yeah yeah and like the harder he
commits to yeah just playing this really
silly moment super dramatically like the
just the the better the comedy lands in
it so I do want to ask about Madonna
um yeah like did you run this by her did
you consult does uh no no no no no no no
the last thing I would have pitched
actually is like I know guyo Siri let's
get a Madonna's approval yeah yeah yeah
I was just dreading the call Donna has
notes guys yeah I think Madonna is still
so focused on her own bio pick that's
right which I think she co-wrote in his
game yeah Diablo Cody which will be I
mean maybe as bananas as our movie
I won't say if it ever comes out but no
we um we worked hard to avoid that
conversation
do you know has she seen it is there any
reaction I mean no I'm I think it's a
great uh she's amazing as Madonna and
the the whole storyline is brilliant
yeah I mean I think
like I I've been a Madonna fan forever
and you know she showed up on Wayne's
World and you know on SNL like in the
90s I I mean I think she has a great
sense of humor
um hopefully about herself uh but even
if she doesn't this is you know it's not
Evan's not playing Madonna she's playing
like an arch Bond villain in a Madonna
costume but like you know she gives it
she has like a little bit of Madonna in
her personality you know um but but it's
very much like an original character
she's creating there yeah it's like
she's as much of Madonna as that as Dan
is of Al yeah it's like one of those
great calls that you get from lawyers
where you're just like yeah this is so
far out there that no one could ever
like basically have a grounds for a
lawsuit because no no reasonable living
human being whatever like imagine that
this is based on her actual life
it's almost like that's why we kill Al
at the end of it it's like just to
definitively say that none of this is
true without having to like put it in
print right right yeah
wow well
[Laughter]
um and Olivia Wilde played Madonna yeah
in the trailer yeah in the original yeah
so we've had great Madonna's
well you know I go to every single
musical biopic they're all bad and I see
them all yeah
um uh but and you hit all the all the
Beats right yeah it's amazing but um
like this movie is a pack of Lies but I
actually feel like I've seen a good
biopic about Weird Al Yankovic I feel
like I yeah I'm like yeah this is like
it's all made up but this is him like I
feel like the spirit of him is I feel
like I know him more yeah it's sort of
like the only way that you could do a
Weird Al biopic is to do it this way
like this says more about him than maybe
his real true story does which is you
know not dramatic enough to make it
interesting movie I don't think very
supportive parents no drugs ask about
the parents no alcohol no cursing
um never curses has never I think he
said his wife has never heard him curse
I've never heard him say a swear word
before yeah wow yeah
so I mean yeah not not like drama
dramatic biopic
material Maybe
um can you talk about the the song that
he did for the film oh yeah we'll have a
Academy campaign
uh yeah so so that song um
you know it kind of came from
I was talking about uh
Amish Paradise like Amish Paradise was
always like the end song of the movie
and there was like a minute where where
I was like
oh I don't know I don't necessarily know
if Amish Paradise
Works after after like hearing the dad's
story because the lyrics didn't really
connect
to the side you know it's like it's not
the story of like the dad's experience
of being Amish
um so I I was pitching to Al that maybe
he write a song
that you know movie owl performs like a
never-before-heard song that he performs
at the award show and uh we ended up
figuring out how to make Amish Paradise
work with the notebook or you know with
like that the Dad wrote the song and it
falls out of the uh SketchBook
and then a week later Al was like you
know what though I've been thinking
about this idea of writing and you know
writing an original song because I I
pitched at the song like was just the
ultimate biopic song about his journey
and he's so I was like What if I write a
song about how everything in the movie
was true and we just played at the
credits at the end and I'm like that's a
better idea
uh so that's that's where that sort of
idea came from and I'm like oh my god
did I just like Inception a weird an
original Weird Al song I'm like I can't
believe that I sort of lit the spark
that you know uh made this song happen
they were like I've been an owl fan for
as long as I can remember there's so
many moments I mean obviously I wrote a
movie with him and we're like personal
friends but like there were so many
Pinch Me moments like making this I got
to go into the studio with like his band
like he recorded all new versions of the
songs for the movie and I got to like go
in with the band and like watch them
play these songs and like you know Al
sent me the mixes you know first he's
like you're the first person in the
world hearing these new mixes of my new
songs and it was like an emotional
moment for me it was really crazy yeah
well the
um I I'd love to hear both of you talk
about sort of what production was like I
mean over like you're shooting during
covid on a very tight budget yeah
actually I don't know what your budget
was I mean a tight timeline yeah
um I can confirm it was tight okay yeah
yeah
I could figure out the budget by how
many days we've got bro but I mean I was
saying the microphone it looks like a
big I think it looks great it looks like
a big movie thank you thank you
um yeah it was uh so what was that
experience like and then kind of
drilling down on one component of it
like all the filming the music scenes
and the performance scenes if you could
talk a little bit about that yeah
um I mean it was tough 18 days uh we
shot this movie in 18 days for those who
have not uh that is insane yeah
um that's like one Game of Thrones fight
scene
yeah I mean I think that the um the big
fight at the diner we shot in four hours
um you know
we were hurt we had rehearsal time
that's one luxury that we had in um in
pre-production which was only five weeks
long too uh but we had a couple of weeks
to rehearse and you know our actors were
super dedicated
um you know Daniel especially he took
accordion lessons
um he he learned enough accordion to
like
you know realistically fake play a
hollowed out accordion in the movie so
we wouldn't have to like waste time
shooting around it and then getting
insert shots of you know someone else's
hands playing
um he learned a bunch of dance
choreography that like a surgeon uh
performance that you saw is
cut way down there's like
it's like twice as long there's verses
and there's like a big dance you'll see
it in the Yankovic cut
uh but there's like you know he had to
learn like choreography
um and the guys in the band too like we
cast actors that could play the real
instruments they all learned how to play
the songs you know we did band
rehearsals wow so you know that that
helped out
um we shot all that concert stuff in one
day
um you mean the big the big concert yeah
the big the doors thing eat it and like
a surgeon
um we shot that all in one day in
Pasadena at the Performing Arts Center
we also shot
the whole like breakup with the band you
know down in the tunnel the fight with
the bandwidth drunk Al this that same
day
uh and it was we did it in like less
than 12 hours
um yeah we had it they we were allowed
we hired a lighting technician so we
like pre-programmed all the lights to
the song
um and it was just a lot of I mean like
pre-production it was a lot of me just
having to make creative editorial
choices in pre-production rather than
post so it was like I had to be super
economical with how I shot it I had to
like only get what I knew I was gonna
use which made the editing process a lot
easier
um but there's certain things where you
know we have one two takes like our
actors are so good and they were so
prepared
and they really got what we were going
for you know it was very easy to give
them Direction because I didn't have to
give that much of it
um but like a scene in that Escobar
scene Evan has that whole thing at the
end where she's
um explained like we should take over
the cartel and and that that whole big
you know monologue of hers uh that's one
take
uh we had one take and we had 20 minutes
at the end of the day
we were just and that was a day where
like near the end of the schedule we had
to cut our days a little short we were
getting a little close to going over the
budget and it was like we have to do 10
hour days now
and we had what you know I'm like okay I
could get maybe three takes if I'm
really quick at giving notes of this
performance
so she does take one at the end of it a
little piece that we cut off was like
when she's crying after he uh Al exits
in a cloud of cocaine dust
and she starts crying and then she
starts doing these dance moves and like
falls down to the ground right and when
she gets back up her wig had gone into
the blood that Dan wiped the Escobar
like he wiped The Medallion off and she
had blood in the wig and it was like
well you know this is so it's going to
take 40 minutes to like take the wig off
clean it dry it put it back on and um
wow it was like all right let's just dab
it dry and then fall back and get one
like big wide shot yeah you know so it
was
yeah
yeah I mean Appel nailed it I mean the
the crew was amazing everyone was just
so locked in and just kind of like
bought into the mission it was like a
passion project yes top to bottom and
also but Eric has been shooting that way
since we started working together in
2008 he was always so fast he always
knew what he wanted and so when we were
having these conversations with Roku and
potential buyers and they were just like
are you sure you guys can pull it off
and I was just like I wouldn't say we
could unless Eric was directing it and
and I think those reps that we had
together as a producer and as a writer
director at funnier die working with
talent and shooting quickly and getting
creative and like you would cheat
different scenes from different you
would kind of like Frankenstein some
things too just to like make sure you
had everything and then it was also
convenient in post because if someone
asked like hey do you have this we could
have just always fall back and like oh
you only gave us 18 days to shoot so
like this is uh everything we got and so
it was really a testament to him leading
that and really setting the tone for the
entire set and an owl too Al is I mean
he works so hard he's so nice incredible
was he on set a lot he was there every
day every single day yep yep from from
call to rap every day
um you know he wouldn't really like
you know he he he would watch you know
he would sit at the monitors uh with us
but he let me do my thing and wouldn't I
mean we we didn't do a lot of like
improv we this is this is the script
like we shot the script
um and uh you know Al would only really
step in with notes usually it was like
Performance Based accordion stuff and
um he was generally just like psyched he
was like happy with everything and it
was a real joy to just watch him watch
at video Village because also so many of
the the celebrity cameos are friends of
his and everyone just came out to
support him yeah that pool party scene
when you talk about the cameos I mean
you had everyone in there it's an
amazing and the way they're shot it's
just yeah thanks it was it was really
um it was like Al gave me his Christmas
card mailing list you know
um so here's like everyone that I'm
comfortable with just reaching out to
personally
um you know and then I see names on
there like Conan O'Brien and Michael
McKeon and You Know Jack Black and uh
yeah it was like Al you know when it was
that all just a day that was a day that
pool party was a a day again a shared
day it was also the scene in Dr
demento's office where the uh they're
like making out on the couch
like that was that same day too but
having all that talent in there and it
was the coldest day of the year yeah
there were supposed to be people in the
pool but it was like too cold even with
heating the pool it was too cold to put
people in there really windy really
windy it was like gonna rain the sun
kept coming in and out it was like
maybe the most difficult day I've ever
had shoot you know trying to get it done
but yeah you have Jack Black who like
does on the first take I'm like all
right do we move on I mean he just
that's he's such like a savant like he's
such an incredible performer he just
shows up and does it yeah
well um Rayne Wilson was amazing as Dr
Demento and yes yes
really incredible and I just so you had
doc was Patton in the trailer was Dr
Demento yeah yeah I was happy to see
that part fleshed out in the movie it
was like yeah I mean he's so critical
thing to the story and it's like I mean
I don't know what Weird Al and Dr
demento's actual uh I mean it's not
quite like that
Dr retro tried to adopt him try to adopt
it right yeah I mean we really based the
relationship of um it's it's Jack Horner
and Dirk Diggler
you know he steps in to become the
father figure and and uh you know and
gets burned by his star you know that
well you know when he uh gets lost yeah
um but rain was uh yeah again just
so perfect for this and totally got what
we're trying to do and
um yeah like the the most surprising
thing when directing this was those
moments those emotional Beats
when we were filming it and like they
were working you know like like we have
rain in in like a bathtub
covered in bubbles and giving this
meaningful like I saw something in you
and we're watching it it's like oh wow
yeah this is really oddly like he's
really nailing this
um moments when like when when uh Daniel
and Toby Haas who's incredible amazing
when they're you know in the factory and
he's like what are you doing dad and his
eyes are welling up you know that oh I'm
not good at turning cranks now like it
was just played so real and but like his
eyes are welling up with tears and Al
and I are sitting behind the monitors
giggling like I can't believe someone's
letting us make this movie
this is so crazy
wow yeah
um and um when did Roku get involved
were they did they buy it when you were
sort of finishing up or were they
involved earlier they were involved
earlier and we were very happy to have
them involved yeah uh we the executive
there Colin Davis who has been a great
champion of this movie uh he actually
worked at quibby if you guys recall the
the great the Great quibby era I met him
on equip I did a quibby I met him on a
quibby yeah
um and so he was a real he actually
wanted it to want to buy that quibby but
then quibby didn't have time to to do it
essentially uh and then we were
fortunate that he went over to Roku was
still really passionate about the
project and we were able to collaborate
and it was just really kind of a perfect
partnership yeah yeah Roku has been like
incredible and let us make this exactly
the way we wanted to make it and yeah
really very very very little
interference on that end and have been
just like so incredibly supportive of
the project and and getting it out there
and letting us
you know I mean it's going to be on the
Roku Channel but they've let us do all
these film festivals and like you know
get it out there in front of people and
and you know give people like these
special theatrical experiences like this
so that's very cool that's great well
thank you so much for for being here
tonight yeah thank you
tell everyone to watch it
thank you for having us thank you both
thanks for coming out yeah thank you
thank you everybody
foreign
[Music]